do you see what uh glenn greenwald
tweeted recently let me see if i can
find this
because we're gonna rag on the media now
about journalism yeah glenn greenwald
tweeted give me more
if you think the real power centers in
the u.s are the proud boys
4chan and boogaloos rather than the cia
fbi nsa wall street in silicon valley
and spend most of your time battling the
former while serving the latter as
stenographers
your journalism is definitely ish
accurate yeah how will swear so adult
family friendly how weird is it that a
hardcore conservative like me is saying
yeah glenn griego
got a good point i mean this guy is not
a conservative like i am
definitely not he's progressive no but
we but
you know i i think we have a common
framework
where we want institutions that function
you know we we've been talking about
this a little bit we've talked about it
before moral frameworks
and we were talking about how the united
states is founded upon a judeo-christian
moral framework yes
whether or not secular individuals
realize it or not when they say things
like i don't get my morals from the
bible
you actually do like you were raised in
a culture that valued certain things
free speech
classical liberalism if you grew up in
china you'd have a different set of
beliefs if you grew up in india if you
grew up in pakistan
the people there have a different
culture and different set of beliefs you
didn't naturally come to the ideas of
classical liberalism
it actually took a very long time the
american revolution was proof of that
i bring that up because what i think
we're seeing is
why is it a staunch conservative like
yourself is sitting here going like
glenn greenwald is correct
well it's because your moral framework
is based on the same similar ideas true
or
mostly the same while you disagree on a
ton of policy and political ideas
exactly
you come from a similar root moral
framework these
these woke leftists and all these
democrats have a completely different
moral framework
exactly they have they have completely
rejected it and that is one of the
reasons our institutions are collapsing
their generation i call it uh cultural
trust fund babies
right none of these guys built these
institutions the institutions all
really came into being before or after
world war ii you look at
look at academia right you know a call
they haven't changed that much you look
at college today the way they teach and
college the way they taught in 1946
yeah you got some video and stuff now
but essentially it's some guy standing
in the front of the room
from a bunch of hungover students you
know yapping at them
all our institutions from the news media
to the
to department of justice academia
uh even the nfl they're all tired and
exhausted and they are run by
the cultural trust fund babies look at
the kennedys
you know john f kennedy kind of a
dynamic guy
third generation kennedys they're at a
crack house
i mean that and that's who are these
guys who run
things you know they haven't achieved
anything they didn't build it except the
tech guys
they kind of did so that's a little
different but other than tech
all the institutions are run by people
who didn't build them didn't create them
and are frankly unworthy they're just
inheritors they say they got a
credential
they say generational wealth only lasts
three generations
bingo you've got the first generation
that earns it yep the children who saw
their their
you know parents working and then the
grandkids who have no idea
and just got money and lived with it
bingo and they are
squandering that inheritance now they
you know these guys they think that this
whole american thing where they live
prosperous and safe
is like the natural state of being dude
get out more
okay you've been to the favelas and i
hope i pronounced that right yeah brazil
yeah i've been to complex yeah the
biggest favela
yes not not a lot like america it's
getting better
but you're right but but it's a very
different stay in nature they
pacified them that's what it was called
when the it was the i think it was the
was it the bopy or it might have been
the kore there's these two different
like
swat groups they went in with big guns
and they killed everybody who got in the
way exactly yeah
the thing is they they because they
didn't build it
because they didn't suffer to create it
they didn't earn it they're squandering
it and they think it's always going to
be there for them
but if things degenerate to the natural
state of man which is power
i think they've got a problem no
definitely because the
a lot of these people are not
particularly well suited
to a world where life is nasty brutish
and short
they don't think it exists let me let me
tell you you know the one of the first
lessons of being a
you know like a cd hustler music hustler
in the street you may have seen these
people back when cds were bigger they
were walking around the city
and they got a stack of cds and like yo
yo here buy my cd buy my cd
and you're like i don't know who you are
i don't know your music is why would i
buy your cd
there's a reason why they don't give the
cd away they want you listen to their
music but they know
they give you the cd for free you're
gonna do you're gonna throw it away
throw in the trash
yeah but if you give him a buck for it
now you're like i bought this like i'm
not i don't wanna finally just gotta
listen to it
yeah well it's something of value that
that i had to you know work for you give
some
you get them for free and they don't
value anything you put on it's my
chemical romance and you go damn it i
wish i'd thrown it away well i don't
think my chemical
romance is going around selling cds in
the street i don't know maybe they
should
are they still a thing yes they are i
don't know
maybe like really 17 years ago i don't
know it's like a crappy band you know
all right get back is easy but you know
just offend all the balloons i'd rather
go with the
i'd rather go with the my chemical
romance don't they play a song that
everyone plays at prom
i don't know sure yeah i don't know i'm
a replacements in clash
so yeah well so anyway this is it's a
really i think it's a really important
point because we were talking a lot
about this yesterday with depressed
millennials
how they don't work they sit around all
day
and then you were mentioning something
interesting you you were saying that for
many of these people
the lockdown is like their woodstock it
is i and i'm going to write about this a
town hall on uh monday
this is excitement look why are
dystopian novels
so and entertainment so exciting why do
people actually put up with watching the
walking dead
because it shows them what a world would
be like
that they're in but actually has
challenges
has risks human beings like excitement
look you were telling me a little
earlier about how you got
gassed by tear gas oh yeah to see i mean
let's look at objectively
what kind of lunatic goes towards a
chemical irritant
i did when i was in the army i
volunteered
and then we were like okay now you gotta
go in this chemical uh
you know this little hot we're gonna
burn cs and make your eyes water we're
like
no no no but secretly we're like if i do
that i'm pretty cool
yeah and you went towards it too well so
there's a reason
we're trying to document what's going on
in these conflicts so i was in brazil
i've been in a bunch of different
conflicts in the us you know riots and
stuff
brazil substantially more brutal and
just the story was
in the u.s i see all of these activists
all these lefties
getting probably the lowest grade cs
smoke i've ever experienced in my life
and and it's like your eyes are for kids
well the police say it's not even tear
gas oh it's just smoke don't worry but
it is an irritant it is it is tear gas
it's just the lowest grade
and i see these people like coughing and
gagging and crying and everything
when i was this stuff is nothing when i
was in brazil they use like the top-tier
military-grade stuff that was so intense
like the guy i'm with has got like just
snot pouring out of his face and he's
braving through it because he's been in
actual war
his eyes are swollen i'm sitting there i
ripped my sweaty sock off shoved at my
mouth
and we run through the smoke to keep
filming the brazilian rioters
they did the same thing like these
people have have seen real hardship and
real conflict yeah
these american you know they're soft man
americans are soft
see that was the purpose a lot of hard
people
did a lot of hard work to allow a
generation
not to have to do any of that but the
problem is human beings
it's like if you don't exercise you get
fat and lazy but
but mentally you also get kind of kind
of fat and lazy
if you're not challenged that's why you
know
people do extreme sports do
skateboarding you get screwed up
skateboarding
you get hurt and you don't do that
because i i mean
but but you do it anyway because it
fills a need inside you
and i i i you know and i i think
some of the antifa stuff is a little bit
of that
too uh of course they want conflict yeah
but they want to
prove conflict right they know they're
good they know the charges are gonna get
dropped yep
they know the cops not gonna shoot them
that's why we call it larping
it is it's really funny i was that i was
at one of these protests it was a riot
slash protest it was a right because
auntie showed up and attacked people but
it was a bunch of
it was like patriot prayers a bunch of
right-wing groups singing religious
songs in a park in a federal park in
portland
antifa showed up with weapons and bricks
and they were they were chanting nazi
larpers at the right wingers
who didn't even pay attention to
anything they were saying the right-wing
group showed up showed up literally to
have an event
to be religious it was like a religious
event antifa showed up
thinking they were nazis accusing them
of being
live at larp's live-action role play and
i'm talking to these people and i'm like
you realize they don't know or care
about who you are or what you're doing
they're singing songs about jesus
literally they were singing songs about
jesus in america you guys have shown up
dressed in black with weapons thinking
you're fighting in a war you're
live-action role-playing
there's no war it's just it's just like
there's a 50-year-old guy there with a
beard and he's in he's he's talking
about why he likes religion he's not
talking about oppressing anybody
you guys have shut up to attack and beat
people this is what they do
they they need a purpose their lives are
meaningless yes
and so they found something to fill the
void so they go around
thinking they're fighting this grand
battle as la resistance when in reality
the cops are like
these dumb kids the charges get dropped
they get told to go home
at a certain point you gotta you've
gotta punish the kids
you know what i mean and i'm not saying
lengthy prison sentences or beatings or
anything like that i'm saying
at a certain point you arrest them you
charge them and then they get you know
two weeks in jail or something or a
month in jail whatever the penalty is
for burning down buildings and smashing
windows
uh right now it's baby proofed
it's baby proof they they know they're
not gonna get hurt and what what
really chaps me is watching what's
happening with the uh
uh capitol hill people from january 6th
yeah they're getting the they're getting
their bricks down they're getting
they're getting the book thrown at them
and then guys importantly are getting
tossed out
there's got to be one standard you can't
have to it is
unsustainable to have two standards
history teaches that for god's sake
people
don't flush what we have here down the
toilet for your
short-term gain no no no you don't
understand
see the p see all these dumb people who
go around larping
don't realize that the useful idiots for
those that want the system torn down by
any means necessary
that's their intent and so built up with
them in charge
yes but it's not so much like you know i
i know many of these people i've
i've spoken with them during occupy wall
street the way they described it was
they said we want to flip the pyramid
over most people
when they hear that make a very simple
assumption you have the pyramid with the
wealthy on top and on the bottom is the
working class
you flip it over and now the working
class are on top you know what i said
if you took a stack of bricks in the
shape of a pyramid flipped it over it'll
crumble into a crude pyramid
yes it'll crumble into a pile of bricks
with one of the working class on top and
they went
exactly that's going to be us yeah
that's going to be us
so they're not talking about taking the
system and
they're quite literally talking about
burning everything you hold dear to the
ground
and then standing on top of the rubbles
and yelling at you to go fetch them
water
and food they know the end result of
this will be total cast and destruction
they want it because to them being the
king of chaos
is better it's a higher standard of
living than they are as a working class
individual
so maybe there's you know hundreds of
millions of working-class people in this
country
they don't care they think that they'd
be better off doubling their net worth
if that they would make themselves the
richest people in the country
with a net worth of 100 bucks if it
meant they were the richest person in
the world they would destroy
everything just to be on top of
everybody else it is
absolute corruption and and drive for
power
no i i think you're correct and i
also think that they have not thought
this through
particularly well there are you know
history is rife with examples
of people pushed too far and right now
we have a system where people
still believe in the system at essence
people are still using the court system
they're used to using the law
they're still appealing to the media and
it doesn't always work it doesn't work
the way it should
but it's not complete chaos yet but boy
what if it was and people
realized i've got nothing to lose then
it's then you start seeing
really ugly potential stuff and that's
what we have to stop
you know that's that's but you know what
these
antifa types and far leftists actually
will survive a lot better than your
average american
now i don't mean conservatives like the
conservatives who are paying attention
to news
who know how to use guns and know how to
actually be out in the wilderness and do
hard work
well they're gonna be in the top tier in
let's say the entire country breaks down
for some reason
and it's just chaos survivalists are
going to be the kings of the castle
they've already got their castles they
got their food they don't need nothing
from you and they're armed to the teeth
you're going to have a series of of
conservative groups and ex-military who
are going to be doing very very well
organizing they've already got their
friends they've already got their
training
they'll they'll you know harden up plus
the militias regular liberals will be at
the very bottom
antifa will be above them these regular
urban city types who've never fired a
gun
who've never grown food who just work in
their office job
will have nothing no skill translatable
to the real world in terms of survival
it is uh you know i i remember reading
uh max
brooks uh world war z there's a very
entertaining book
yeah and there is a scene in there where
a uh
a rich per rich lady is being taught how
to clean houses
and by her former maid right the whole
society is broken down again the
dystopian thing psy's broken down and
the maid is teaching this woman how to
clean houses
because everybody's got to have a skill
because everybody's got to work okay you
can't be a diversity consultant anymore
you know we don't need a more gender
studies teachers uh we we need somebody
who knows how to disinfect the toilet so
people don't get sick
field sanitation is an important thing
and uh i just that that just struck me
a lot of these people rely on
the framework of society that they're
busy
supporting the people undermining that's
right and it just it's
it's baffling to me thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you